we heard there from David gork that one
of the big challenges not just for the
conservatives but also for the country
are these strikes
um it's been a difficult year for the
conservatives what's Labor's plans to to
take on these strikes I mean how would
the labor party do things differently
well we're in the Midland we have a Tory
winter of discontent and the problem
that we've got is we've got a government
that at best is doing nothing to resolve
them and the worst is actively
sabotaging uh the the con the
discussions that could lead to an end to
these Stripes so the first thing labor
would do and I and my colleagues have
all said this for for weeks now on these
or on your shows is that we would sit
down bring both sides together and just
get them talking and in many cases you
know the nurses have said this if the
talks were to begin then the strikes
would not continue and the reason that
you know nurses are are are taking for
the first time in our nhs's history
industrial action is because after 10
years in which their pay in real terms
has been cut by around 20 they're now
facing another massive real terms pay
cut because inflation is soaring and
nurses are having to go to food banks to
get food and can't afford to eat their
homes and clothe their children that is
not a situation we should allow to
happen in this country
I'm sorry to jump in there of course
everyone agrees that there should be
some talking but we're talking must come
action so if a labor party uh was in
government and you were faced with
exactly the same situation during those
talks how much money would you offer the
public sector workers to call off these
strikes
what you don't do is go into talks
already having declared the outcome
because that isn't really a conversation
that's that's just an instruction so
that wouldn't work but I I know this is
not just about pay it's also about terms
and conditions
it's one of the things they'll tell you
is that the pressure on them in the
hospitals is immense we lost my dad uh
in the summer so I was speaking to
nurses who were I was just so in awe of
the care and love that they were giving
to him and the rest of our family at
that at that time but there were nurses
there working double shifts because
there weren't enough nurses so one thing
labor would do to counter that is we
would scrap the non-dom tax status that
allows billionaires to pay no tax at all
in our country and use the three billion
that that would generate to fund the
biggest increase in nurses that we've
ever seen in our National Health Service
to alleviate some of the pressure on
nurses that is a real thing you could
put on the table as part of those as
part of those negotiations and I think
we need to be looking a longer term than
just a single year pay settlement as
well now all of that will come out of a
negotiation but if you're not even
talking you can't possibly get to a
solution and we've got a government that
is sitting back and refusing to even
allow those talks to go ahead that is
negligence
Okay so
three billion is it does sound like a
lot of money but given the the overall
state of the the NHS budget it is rather
a drop in the bucket
assuming there are other plans to tackle
this what what could the public look
forward to if a labor government were to
come in in 2023
well I mean I mean I don't think it's
fair to say three billion is a drop in
the ocean that's you know that that
would be the single biggest increase in
nurses and doctors our NHS has ever seen
in its entire history so I think that is
a very practical measure now you know
the underlying cause of all of this is
that we've got a government that's lost
control of the economy we all accept the
situation in Ukraine and with Russia has
fueled
um inflation but it's done that across
the whole of the world and yet the
United Kingdom has got the lowest growth
out of the 38 members of the oecd and
the reason for that is this government
hasn't got a clue how to grow the
economy so Labor's put on the on the
table at our conference this year kirst
armor outlined a green Prosperity plan
that would allow us to invest in
transforming the economy to you know the
green economy investing in Wind wave
solar Take Back Control of our energy so
we're not subject to these massive
fluctuations that we're seeing across
the world and the chairman of Tesco's
not a member of the labor party the
chairman of Tesco said that there's only
one player on the pitch when it comes to
economic growth and that's labor so you
know we saw on the last Labor government
grew the economy twice as fast as this
conservative government has done if we
can grow the economy as labor has shown
we can there's more money to share
around but right now we need to tackle
the immediate issues and in the Health
Service one of those is the immense
pressure that our nurses and doctors are
put under in a way that they simply
can't cope with working double shifts
and not having enough money to pay their
bills